All right bladesmiths,
there will be a strength test,
a sharpness test.
And up first, Doug
Marcaida's kill test.
Doug.
Bladesmiths, a Hanzo
katana's first duty is to kill.
All right, Mike,
and you're up first.
Are you ready?
- Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
Yes.
Mike, your edge
is razor sharp.
But more importantly,
there's bone on your edge,
but your edge did not
roll, did not chip,
and your blade stayed true.
Overall, sir, your
blade will kill.
Thank you.
Tristan, you ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
Tah!
All right, Tristan, the balance
of your blade is very good.
It's light.
It's fast.
It's easily maneuverable.
But when steel meets the skull,
there were some problems.
Your blade took a serious bend.
Also, on the edge right
here, it took some chipping.
But overall looking
at the dummy,
I think your weapon
will definitely kill.
Thank you.
Gentlemen, the second
duty of a Hanzo katana
is that it is to be sharp.
It is said that the Hanzo katana
is as sharp as a thousand razor
blades.
Now, a sharp blade should cut
cleanly through tatami mats.
A dull blade will crush,
bend, or get hung up.
A dull blade is
not a Hanzo katana.
Mike, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yes, I'm ready.
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
Your blade, sir, is sharp.
It cut cleanly through the
thickest of our tatami mats.
But on the backhand slice, it
did not cut completely though.
Overall, sir, your
sword will cut.
Thank you.
Tristan, your turn.
You ready?
Ready as I'll ever be, sir.
Let's do this.
[gong]
[rock music playing]
[sighs]
Well, Tristan,
your edge is sharp.
It can cut through tatami mats.
My concern is the
strength of your blade.
It picked up another bend.
Now you have two
bends on your blade,
especially right here
close to the guard.
Tristan, this
Hollywood competition
has been exciting and dramatic.
You've been at the epicenter
of all of that drama.
Nobody is questioning the
strength of your character.
However, the strength
of your blade
is such that we can no
longer continue to test it.
And for that reason,
I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
Yes, sir.
Good job.
Guess I just
couldn't slip through.
Second place isn't
bad for somebody
who's never done this before.
Mike, you were an unstoppable
force in this competition,
and your Hattori Hanzo
thousand-layer katana is
absolutely deadly, earning you
the title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and a
check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
I came here to
show myself that I
can make a blade
worthy of undergoing
this type of punishment.
I am "Forged in Fire"
champion, and it feels awesome.